my name is here - axe wall and I was an
electrical engineering and theatre arts
major in my undergraduate here and now
I'm studying Electrical Engineering as a
master student last spring is when I
started having discussions about
possibly directing Einstein's dreams
it was my undergraduate Peter thesis
project the full spring production for
MIT theater arts this year we're going
to be directed by me which is a huge
responsibility because it's usually a
role that's taken on by faculty members
or outside directors so I was both lucky
and very empowered by the entire theater
department to take on this
responsibility there were definitely
times where I was not making decisions
fast enough or I wasn't really quite
sure what I wanted and there was still a
lot of learning on the job as I went
through I mean MIT philosophy is meant
as Mother's Day so it's mind and hand
and these are really more growing
opportunities where you're working on a
show but you realize that you're
learning life skills instead
[Music]
Feinstein streams is about these
different worlds where time runs
differently it explores the human
ramification of the slight manipulation
in time so imagine a world where our
lifetimes just are circular they keep
repeating themselves what effect does
that have on the people living out their
lives in the circular time what effect
does it have when they slowly start to
realize that they're carrying out the
same loop over and over again they can't
break out of it it's also about Einstein
creative journey towards discovering
special relativity so in a way it's his
thought experiments with simply sitting
down and thinking ok well what if time
worked like this then what would happen
in this show there's not a single
Einstein anybody could be Einstein
because this roll is transitioning
through all these three different
actresses Sabri equalities a course to
senior Alexa Garcia is the course 20
senior and I was going into a bowl to
study political science at Wellesley
probing paper I realized that for me
what I was interested was the cost of
creativity the struggles the
frustrations the obsession of the
creative process and that's what I enjoy
doing is also about and that's something
I feel like we all at MIT here can
relate to pretty much anything that's
open-ended and creative and have never
been done before you go through this
very similar journey
[Music]
as a director you're leading the actors
but then you're also collaborating with
all of the designers and leading that
team talking back and forth exchanging
ideas posing questions and seeing their
response your job really is to set the
tone of the room and create a safe
environment where accidents can happen
because sometimes you know an accident
is the most brilliant part of a show in
a way directing a show is very similar
to doing research and that's interesting
because then you can use what you've
learned from one and apply it to the
other so for example some tools and
activities that I've learned in
directing how to brainstorm ideas how to
build off of a problem statement how to
curate different ideas I've actually
been able to use that in my graduate
research also to help me think about
problems how to break things down it's
really until you're in the rehearsal
room making decisions on the job and
when you actually learn what it is to
make work with a group of other people I
decided I wanted to be an engineer
because I felt being an engineer what
gives me the skills and capabilities to
work on really difficult problems but
people are also half of that equation so
how do you communicate this whistle how
do you turn that discovery into an
impact that was my inspiration for
studying both engineering and theatre
here at MIT
[Music]
you